[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - GORDON CHAMBERS,
SONGWRITING MEDLEY"]
GORDON CHAMBERS: So I am
the common denominator
of all those songs.
But it's music lovers like you
that made them all number ones.
So right now, I'm
going to do a song.
On every album,
I cover something
that I've written in
my own special way.
Tonight this one goes
out to a dedication
to two very important ladies
in my career-- my first two
mentors, the late,
great, Phyllis
Hyman, and a lady
that I wrote for,
who told me that it was
time for me to also go solo
as an artist.
Give it up for-- it's one
year since she went to glory.
Give it up for the
beautiful, incomparable,
and forever in our hearts,
Ms. Whitney Houston.
Last but not least,
for my beautiful,
the matriarch of
our family, recently
gone home, Aunt
Barbara, Barbara Powell.
[MUSIC_-_GORDON_CHAMBERS]
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS: Thank you.